[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm linked and
I'm read this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question what happened to toys and we
were just saying what's gonna be funny
if you dislike you just go up to
somebody a friend
Gwaine it's family member acquaintances
and you're just like you know what I got
this nagging question what what happened
to toys because listen something
happened a lot happen y'all okay we're
gonna get into it possibly I'm also
looking forward to getting into our past
lives as children when we played with
toys when toys were still toys and we
play at least I did I'm actually curious
because I have a thought I have some
thoughts about you and I'm I think I'm I
have an idea about red as a child that I
remember that may not even be true but
toys okay the toys if change isn't true
toys have Ching and I'm interested do
they even exist anymore
by my definition I don't know is it is
it a long-lost thing that we can only
experience through nostalgia over the
course of this podcast I can't wait a
little reminiscing a little conjecturing
as always conjecturing pulling things
directly out of our butts and putting
them on the internet and hoping that it
will change lives yep
one pulled out of our butt at a time a
life has changed and I am going to begin
holding the microphone like this okay
that's my new thing alright because I
want to be able to tell listener I just
want you to know that Rhett is now
holding and hovering his microphone
above the roundtable and I made you a
little mini bicep curl did you say this
week is a roundtable that didn't like
you didn't even say that you know what I
did say it and I've noticed something
and it's been happening more and more
often you may need to go to the doctor I
know what you're talking about lately
I've been saying something and then in
the middle of so cliche you say did you
just say did you just say that yeah I
definitely did say it I maybe it is a
problem I mean it's it's happening
weekly now I feel like I'm crumbling
definitely emotionally after what
happened last night
Oh
yeah I I'm gonna link the two because I
think that never heard you use your name
as a verb I'm still kind of really mad
more often and I'm glad you were there
too I'm ready for you to tell me yeah
well I thought that's what we're doing
okay I'm still not over what happened
and I'm sorry if you don't want to hear
us talk about magic and our interactions
with it again but that's not really what
this is about yes what happened last
night
did happen at a visit to the Magic
Castle with our friends she's becoming
as a regular haunt of ours we've got so
many people but I want to go to them
honestly really and I know it's all so
funny but I feel like I'm trying is it
better if if I tell the story of you
tell the story from your perspective
because it's probably better if I tell
it okay I agree with that so tell it
from your perspective I'll just try not
to interject too much just to clarify
what was going on some of mine at the
time and again not to shatter the
illusion that this is recorded all the
date that you're hearing it for us we're
recording this right around Halloween
which means that we went to but it's not
dated because no one's heard it until
right now right yeah I'm not worried
that's all that matters right no it's
fresh and only for you so at the Magic
Castle around Halloween they have a
special thing that they do basic they
call it a murder mystery and you can
where you know you can dress up you can
wear costumes and another thing that
happens is that the performers the
magicians are all in costume as well and
in character they're not just normal
magicians which is cool I will say that
we completely erased it abandoned never
even really started the murder mystery
thing they gave us like a list of clues
and you had to go read something and I
was like this I don't wanna think this
much at the magic
so we abandon that apparently I didn't
either but we went to the close-up magic
gallery which is our favorite place
that's the worst our friend almost got
into a fistfight with Jason sudakis
holds a special place in our hearts and
the guy gets up there and he is
pretending to be Sherlock Holmes putting
on a British accent dressed as Holmes
himself and it begins to go through his
act and he's putting it all in terms of
like solving Clues and you know
intuition that Sherlock Holmes would
have I would say he was good it was good
it was very good yeah I mean he's a
professional magician as far as I could
tell but even the comedic banter I
thought was a nice aspect of it and then
of course for at least half of his act
he requires volunteers from the audience
now link is sitting on the first row in
a very small this is the place holds
like 20 people so it's very small and if
you listen to the other magic podcast
you know that last time I was standing
in the back end I still got made a fool
out of ya I became the butt of the joke
and I was happy I was happy to be that
so he gets to this one trick and he says
for this I need a volunteer and he you
can see there's five people sitting on
the front row link is one of those and
he kind of looks at the five people and
he avoids the people directly in front
of him because he had just used those
two people two of our friends for the
previous trick so he's got it
the three people he's choosing from and
he looks at our friend Jenny and she um
as he looks at her she's going she's
shaking her head and looking down very
very emphatically saying do not pick me
it's like when a horse makes that sound
but I will say did that moment but she
didn't in it now I will say that he
looked at you first yeah now you had
also just done something in the previous
trick where somebody had to say whatever
when they were gonna stop they said when
you say stop when you're compelled to
stop and she didn't she never said stop
so I said stop and I thought that was a
funny joke to compel
grabbed the arm of the volunteer who was
a friend of our and said stop I thought
it was funny and then he you could kind
of see that the guy when he began to
figure out who he's gonna choose for the
next trick he looked at you and he's
like not the guy that just interjected
himself into this previous trick he goes
over to Jenny's she shakes her head and
then he's kind of at a loss he's he
gonna go beyond you out to where
Christie was sitting and then his lands
back on you reluctantly and as he was
picking you I was thinking inside no no
no god dude don't pick don't pick him
don't pick him don't pick him if this
try wasn't wanting to be picked by the
way if this tree wasn't asking requires
a person to do things that a normal
human being would do in response to a
magician you've made a mistake that's
what I was thinking you know again then
95 out of a hundred times that you pick
somebody they're gonna do the thing that
the magician wants and I know that
you're in the elite 5% I'll call it of
people who are not going to behave
normally for a number of reasons so the
trick was the reason the trick was he
put a cup of colored markers in front of
link anything let's call him sharpies
and then not a spots and then gave link
a pad of paper that had three shapes on
it circle a square in a rectangle and he
said sir what I want you to do is I want
you to take one of the markers out of
the cup any color you want and choose to
color any of the shapes that you want no
no he didn't say that he said I'm gonna
turn around and well use a marker and
then he said color the triangle he told
you which was your marker he was like
pick but he didn't say the color the
triangle any color you want and then
he's also facing away from us and he's
coloring now right at the very beginning
you picked up a marker and then put it
back down and got another marker and at
that point is that a crime at that point
I figured that probably screwed this guy
up right because it's probably based I
don't know how the trick works
but it has something to do with him
knowing what you've chosen and if you
don't if you choose two of them his
whole trick is screwed right all I knew
was that everybody was watching me pick
a marker so I'm like oh I'm like I'm
like fluttering my hand over the marker
and yeah and then I'm like being a
little extra I agree and then and I'm
like oh I'm am I gonna choose this one
no and then I'll let go of it and I
chose another one and then he said color
try gonna did it and then two more times
did the same thing and I'm just thinking
I'm just choosing markers man no I will
say trying to be thought I'm trying to
have silly trying to have fun and be
silly or have silly if you want but I
wasn't trying to do I would no ill
intent you were not you didn't think
honestly that the trick hinged on you
just grabbing a marker and holding it up
were you supposed to hold it up how
could it and I'll say
because he continued on with the trick I
was like oh okay maybe he didn't screw
it up yeah I did this three times guys I
picked three different markers and
colored the three different shapes and I
see as he continued to color shapes
after all three shapes were colored and
the magician had colored his shapes as
he turned around and faced us I saw a
look in his face of utter disappointment
he knew that his trick had failed busted
any knew that it was your fault the
funny thing is I didn't know by the way
all the all the shades were colored
different colors than mine and I was
still hoping that it was part of the
trick and then he just put it down on
the floor he put it on the floor he said
usually that's very impressive yeah I
was like haha but he said a few more
things and he put it on the floor and
then he continues with his act yeah so
then at the very end he did like two
more things they were great I'm laughing
just having a Bevan a silly time ballin
and then ballin then I realized he's
done he's like said his last thing it's
over he's like telling her a goodbye you
can stand up here's the exit and I'm and
then I say oh hold on a second
I know that I didn't that I colored that
exactly how you told me to so I I know I
didn't do something wrong so why don't
you show me the show me the picture that
you really drew and then he said that
was it and at that moment after everyone
else had already long realized this I
realized I blew his trick it took me
that long you realized that's what I
really because I thought when he always
he's doing the long play at the very end
he's gonna be like and you know what I
do have the one that is exactly like his
I had that much faith in the guy and I
also because I had no ill intent I
really thought I hadn't screwed up his
trick and then as we're leaving I'm like
it's really dawning on me and I start
turning everybody in the griffon I'm
like I messed up the guy's trick yeah I
messed up his trick and then as I'm
doing that some person not in our group
mm-hm storms up to me mm-hmm I was
talking to you at the time another
patron a woman uh she was in some sort
of a costume but I couldn't tell you
what it was mm-hmm
go-go dancer maybe I don't think so she
put a finger in my face and what did she
say she said by the way sir not cool not
cool she said it again and then we did
she stormed off you know our friends
looks like eyes she was walking off I
was like I I didn't mean to
right but just to put things into
perspective this probably makes sense
but there is a there is an understanding
in the magician's community I don't know
what the technical term is for it but
people who know how a trick works know
enough about magic to know how a trick
works and when picked to be a volunteer
purposely set boil the trick yeah for
some own personal gain or just to be of
troll and so lots of people thought that
you were a troll and that woman who is a
magician's aficionado obviously that's
what she was dressed as okay you had a
look like a fairy but any retrospect
right I understand why she did it
because if you had done it intentionally
it was a complete douche thing to do and
especially at the end when I'm like hold
on hold on show the picture because I
know I drew it and you told me to bring
it in and I thought I was giving him an
opport as as stupid as it sounds I
thought I was giving him an opportunity
because I thought he was about to to
like blow our minds one last time
thought it required you to ask I was a
part you thought part of it was you oh I
have to wait for a solution to finish
the trick I'm like a child when I go
into the Magic Castle oh my gosh I drew
it with childlike wonder I experienced
everything
oh I'm picking markers which one am I
gonna pick maybe this one nope this one
why so much fun I would never choose you
yes if I was doing a trick but let me
know any honestly he did he tried not so
bad after this that I was like the PERT
the person who invited us like the
member I was like I went up to her as
like her reputation is although I was
like I am I want to let you know that I
didn't do it intentionally I am so sorry
I would and you know and then a few
minutes later I'm like you know what I'd
like to talk to the guy yeah if there's
any way I could talk to him and
apologize I'll make it better I ended up
she came and got me a little bit later
and went out there and he was Sherlock
Holmes was standing out there and sad
disappoints yeah he was apologetic he's
like you know what I the first thing he
said was I should have been more clear
and I'm like hold on no no no and then
he starts talking he's like when you
picked up the marker and I was like whoa
I don't know how to do your trick I
don't want to know I just want you to
know I want to look into your eyes and I
want to say I did not do that on purpose
I'm just an idiot and I'm so sorry that
would be a good teacher I did not do
that on purpose I'm just an idiot
I heard it man I felt horrible I put my
forehead on his shoulder that's how bad
I felt you did I've never done that to a
stranger I was like that was a little
bit later I was like I thought I was
gonna start crying on the guy's shoulder
he thought I was if he probably thought
I was a totally
yeah uh I couldn't go to sleep I was
thinking about it
well you here's what it wasn't I have a
reputation it's like in our home has a
reputation who impulse as we were all
dressed as the same I just I mean I've
experienced a lot of success from just
going with it and just being impulsive
but I I think maybe for the first time
this was a whoa buddy look what you've
done now you've totally shaped you I
could have shaken the foundations of my
magicians career I did you did well but
it was a small audience I think he could
you know I think it maybe it's good for
him he I think he learned a lesson
first of all go with the instinct to not
pick the person that you think is gonna
foil the trick and go to the second rope
go beyond the first road go to the
second or when that happens you gotta
have a contingency plan yeah you can't
be dead in the water who knows you
screwed up the trick my advice would
have been as soon as you screwed up the
trick he should have backed out and said
something like something some bad juju
from you I'm gonna use this other person
and then we would have been able to see
the trick go but you know what I but I
know nobody intended you didn't have bad
intention you haven't lived life until
you know what it feels like to foil a
magician's trick unintentionally it's
like being at a comedy club and a
stand-up comedian is up there and you
find yourself trying to let your like
stand up I'm gonna give you a compliment
and then you you end up like heckling
him and decimating him how is that even
possible that's what I feel like I did
but I don't think I need that in my life
I feel like all of me that I haven't
lived in delight hey comedian I think
you're great I want to do everything I
can to support you ironically I'm
murdering you right now that's what I
felt like I did well don't be so hard on
yourself just don't do it again
I did I do feel like I was making it
about me because I was choosing the
marker and that was just going on
instinct and I don't know if I should
back off of that because I've built a
hooker here on it well I think that but
in that set I think the application of
it is in the moment where you're
supposed to be just behaving like a
normal person
I can't bringing the attention onto
yourself might be less than desirable
for the person who the attention is on I
wasn't you want I wasn't even trying to
bring the attention to myself
I'm not even once I've found that I had
the attention I'm not just saying it was
completely I'm not saying that you were
thinking about it I'm saying that in
order to not do that you would have to
be intentional to be like okay I've been
chosen as a mark in this thing and now
I'm gonna behave as I should as a normal
human did you notice what I did for the
two other acts after that whenever they
were choosing people you look down I
bowed my head well I don't have my head
that's in great art then I would not be
chosen again okay then I left early but
we got to talk about stay we got to talk
about toys we could talk about the Magic
Castle over and over and over again we
probably las iam but we're gonna talk
about toys but before that we're gonna
let you know that you can outfit
yourself yes with the forest and farm
collection starting with your head look
at that these are the the latest and hat
technology you just stick it right on
the front of your head and you hold it
like this this is of course a miniature
horse which is one of my loves and this
is a piece of wood which is one of my
loves we also have shirts and socks that
go along with this to go to mythical dot
store to pick those up of course you
can't get red shirt here's the deal the
reason I decided to wear this shirt is
not only because I love the color
palette but because I want to show you
tangibly the ugly shirt what it means
when we say for a limited time okay in
fact almost everything we're doing now
is for a limited time we put it in the
store if you like it you've got a shot
at it because when it sells out we're
moving on as is the case with this
incredible shirt that I'm wearing right
now I'm not even gonna say what it is
because then I'd have to say something
else but it's really awesome it's really
cool I choose to roll the sleeves up you
can't trigger your own saying of that
whose freakin phone is that that's my
computer
my wife is one of the FaceTime with me
and she's in Malaysia like I should take
this all right do it oh gosh she's in
bed dude you can't hey I'm currently
podcasting but I really wanted to answer
this and tell her that I'm here like
keep your covers up it's in it's early
morning in Asia okay should I give her
my mic well I don't know if I should
have this conversation I think we should
have this conversation later I love you
too stay right there okay I'll call you
when I'm done with it you know what
let's just let's don't do this you know
you've got a life this is just our
podcast okay that was interesting you
muted it that's good
I did okay that was a risk man that's a
relief this is still the ad by the way
oh here's what you get with the video
version okay yes dad we're actually
gonna splice in footage of that video
call okay that's impossible
let's talk about toys the other night I
was talking to Lando into bed and he was
Lincoln wasn't going to bed because I
think it was a weekend and he was
staying up watching a movie or something
a little later but Lando still needed to
go to bed but he doesn't like to go to
sleep if Lincoln's not in the next room
okay so I was like you know what I I
will stay in your room as long as you
want and hang out with you while you go
to sleep we installed this hammock swing
that's like a seat beside his bed he
really wanted one of those and I just
inside I was like I'm gonna sit in this
hammock swing comes out of the ceiling
it's attached to the ceiling yeah just
to hang you down in a joist in a joist
yeah I've crossed me
when that lando has an exposed beam in
his ceiling if you must know this is
what you care about so started leave the
well I mean the story's not going to a
failed swing it has nothing to do with
it a what I don't want your life to go
to a failed swing that's why I'm just
checking in and making sure oh thank you
yeah I was like I'm gonna sit in your
swing you're gonna lay in the bed and
we're just gonna talk you know manage
you know talk
I'm never too mammatus like we do when
we speaking it up speaking the made-up
language I'm a banana I'm going nuts
madness yeah I was gonna say imagine
that imagine that we're just gonna sit
here and have a conversation
yeah as family Moo does that talks to
each other right I thought it would be
refreshing and cool and I didn't have
anywhere to be
so I sit in the swing and I'm he's
laying there and we're talking and I'm
looking around and I said Lando I'm
realizing something there is something
that I had a lot more of when I was your
age than you have and of course you know
what this is because you already know
what this podcast is about because I've
already tasted but he didn't know
something like can you guess he's like
looking around he's like hammock swings
I'm like no son I actually didn't have a
hammock swing you're good guess though
you're amazing father mounted this for
you because you asked for it but I
didn't have one when I was a kid he was
like chairs he's like looking around and
seeing stuff which is actually he should
have been doing the opposite looking
around for what he didn't see that I had
right I was I ultimately after playing
this game for 45 minutes
mm-hmm not that long I said toys he
eventually guessed Legos cuz he has
Legos in his room I was like not Legos
but broader than that just toys in
general Lando when I was 8 years old I
had a bunch of toys in my room that was
my thing but you don't have
you live in a totally different
eight-year-old world than the world that
I lived in your room looks totally
different it's it's like you're a
different it's like you're it's like
you're on a different planet where toys
don't exist except for Legos and a few
odd nerf bullets planet meridah meridah
meridah yeah and you told me this and I
was like yeah that's definitely the case
now they have they do have toys but they
don't have the number of different toys
right I mean they may have a lot of a
couple of things because I think that's
the case with with my kids now yeah cuz
I mean all my kids have Legos lando has
that he also has like the the bigger
type of Legos called Bionicles
that's basically a version of Lego that
period men he has two Bionicle Legos
that are star wars you know it has some
pop figures because Lilly and Lincoln
really got into those like over the past
few years he's started getting in it
did he ever did he go through the duplo
stage oh yeah course much earlier
you're talking like yeah three years old
but it's because of screens and of
course I started taking him through the
toys that I play with and I'd like for
us to do that with each other but it's
because of screens man they've got games
and shows and at their beck and call at
all points and I was like that's your
problem Lando of course now his eyes
Roy's like oh you're you're attacking my
screens that's what you guys you and Mom
are always talking about the screens but
I'm like when we watch shows it was the
only time kid shows game I was like
Saturday morning and then after school
for like like a two hour window it was
not on-demand and then we were just left
watching adult shows you know like I'd
watch reruns of Matlock or like game
shows stuff that was made for adults
that like kids could tolerate you know
right on Thursday night as probably a
year old
watch Dukes of Hazzard then of course
I'd have to watch Dallas right after it
and my grandma's had to go to bed after
Dukes of Hazzard hey Allie remember the
NBC
don't-don't-don't at the end of the show
and Ida had a go to bed but because the
screens are so pervasive and any and
everything you want oh it's like this
show called fuller house Lando starts
watching that and then he just binge
watches all of it well they also they
it's the access they have to the number
of shows the number of shows that are
you know kind of catered towards them
the fact that they can watch it at any
time and the fact that there's more
screens has created this situation where
they're all watching things incredibly
personalized so at any given time
everybody in your family is watching
something different right on screen with
the headphones on and in their own
hammock and I got it I mean I'm sure
because it's so much more it's such more
it's a passive experience not quite as
much with games but you're gonna
gravitate towards that because the it's
limitless
it's so easy and it's so enthralling
because I think that because as we talk
about the toys that we played with my
theory is that we're going to realize
why given kids compete you just give
somebody the option between something
they have to apply a lot of imagination
to and then something that all the works
been done just the natural human
response is to go towards that thing
that's an easier thing which ultimately
could be a bad thing as well I started
to explain to Lando I was like Lando
when I was your age I was in to these
action figures called he-man
it was actually called Masters of the
Universe and then the main guy was
called he-man and he was a a
muscle-bound and I'm talking extremely
muscle-bound like if this was a real
person it would be like a bodybuilder
who was 6 foot 1 but weighed 800 pounds
like seriously
yeah at very large pecs he had very
large everything except for clothes
which he wore fur
where and then he carried an axe and a
sword and he had like he had war Uggs
and he walked around in Eternia and
fought a purple guy who had just as much
muscle as he did a matter of fact he had
exactly the same amount of muscles same
old was the same mould but his head was
a purple hood with a yellow skull in it
Skeletor
Galit are and only started to he was
like what this this is crazy
and he rode a cat a tiger that well
first of all run with the fact a green
cat with orange stripes called battle he
was a lot like Superman in that he had a
normal non he-man persona that was Adam
right which is a great name not super
persona he wore pink and he he liked to
bake and what was seriously what was the
what was the caste name Cringer Cringer
and then Cringer became that'll cat
battle cat a tiger a Green tiger that
had a saddle and all I did was put a
helmet on right and that's when he
became yeah I don't I don't know what
would make him I can't read that what's
it say Prince Adam Prince a difference
well so okay so you had that I had the I
had the whole set I had the castle I
hope you did yeah at skeletor's castle
and because he had it there was another
little guy like a short ghost it was
like a short ghost guy Orko yeah yeah I
remember whose side he was on he was
like an Oracle like he was gonna win
both people's side I don't know he was
kind of like the Jar Jar Binks of the of
the of Eternia in it like he was just he
looked into inside his face and it was
just I balls and it was dark yeah anyway
I had that whole set and spent quite a
bit of time playing with it the game you
had the castle as well oh yeah I had a
Castle Grayskull I had it at home I also
had one at Nana and Papa's house oh you
had a backup well I just you know it's
kind of like when you get old you have
reading glasses everywhere everywhere
when I hadn't have another Castle
Grayskull which it wasn't
it wasn't skeletor's castle and you know
this is something I only learned from
watching the Netflix documentary which
I'll go ahead and plug it I want to make
sure I get right the toys that made us
if if you're 40 years old for 35 years
old you now then you're gonna love
watching that and hearing all the
backstory about it so I highly recommend
it and that's why it's so fresh in my
mind because I've been watching this
some of the times with the kids and they
get a kick out of it
Castle Grayskull was who whoever whoever
had both sides of the sword that
Skeletor had one hat one half of the
sword one side of the sword and he-man
had the other side and whoever could get
both sides and put them together could
then unlock Castle Grayskull and go
inside and have the power of by the
power of Grayskull hmm you could become
amazing
so who lived in Castle Grayskull well
here's the thing I actually didn't watch
the the cartoons or read the comics that
came with the demon watch the cartoons
I didn't even what I just played with
him I didn't even know the stories I
didn't know what I just told you about
combining the swords I just like
collecting these super weird characters
like beast man or mecha neck a guy whose
neck went up or like this all from
message to the universe yeah did you
have a mall like man many many faces I
had many faces you would twist his head
he would have different faces okay so
but just describe to me well I'll just
quickly say because I want to come back
to how you played with those but like as
I was kind of thinking back the list I
made was those action figure sets that
were based on properties that existed TV
shows movies he-man is the one that was
the first in my mind because it was big
but of course I had GI Joe not to the
degree you did I had to help the whole
Thundercats set which was actually my
brothers that was handed down to me mhm
so all the Thundercats and whatever came
with them I had a absolute craft ton of
Smurfs what because the thing I when I
would go to your house I think we were
older when I started going to your house
I think that's what it was because my
theory was you didn't play with many
toys because what I remember the first
time when your house was posters of
basketball players Michael Jordan spud
Webb dunking in your in your bedroom I
don't remember any toys anywhere well by
the time but that must been later I mean
I definitely I I'm fairly confident that
I stopped playing with them on a regular
basis before you did I mean I yeah none
of this made it to middle school like
not a chance
thanks Curtin didn't definitely make it
a sixth-grade for me this is like first
grade through fourth grade maybe in the
fifth grade also the way by the time you
turn eight typically you're getting out
of like act you figure plate butting
maybe nine years old the other thing
that I think is a little different and
this is evidenced by the way that you
treated your WWF action figure set is
that when I had somebody over I was like
that's not time to play with toys like I
was like I got somebody over we're going
to go outside yeah we're gonna go
outside we're gonna get into something
these toys are for when it's raining and
I have to be in my room last resort the
toys were not something I I was super
excited about them initially I would set
them up but then within seven days I was
missing pieces of it it was kind of
weird and kind of off and I never like
tried to like I did you create like
stories with them because I would like
play with them a little bit and then I
would combine a bunch of them and then I
would kind of lose interest and move on
to something broum them into a box that
you wouldn't open
well yeah knowing I mean knowing that
you now as well as I do and and applying
that backwards I would say you probably
lost interest whereas I would dig deep I
remember four GI Joe was the one and I
was telling land of this two I was like
it's army men but they're like fully
articulated imposable and that's when I
realized I told her I was like you know
I didn't so much as play with my GI Joe
men as a collect them and then I read a
lot about like they also they had like
das
like they're on the back of the
packaging it would like describe all of
their their detailing but I look a I
would collect him and be I would just
I'd set up a pose them you know that
they had they could there they had a
hole in their boot and then they had
pegs on all their vehicles and so you
could stand them up and like put them in
dynamic poses and as I was telling land
of this I realized you know what I
didn't play with my toys
I created still life like that's what I
did I would I remember I got the mobile
command center like the biggest thing
that GI Joe had made it like it opened
up like a three tiered tackle box and it
was as huge as this table at least in my
memory and I would take all of my GI Joe
guys and I would position them all over
and pose them and then once I got it
exactly how I wanted it I'd leave it and
when I came back to it I would just look
at it as if I were walking through a
museum and someone had created a still
life yeah and if I ever went to the
trouble of setting it up and again I
would put uh it wasn't like great castle
grayskull just had a man it was like
Castle Grayskull could have Smurfs in my
world I think it's hilarious that you
were big into Smurfs like what do you
mean I don't even know what you mean her
little figurines none I know a star no
no I'm specifically describing them they
were about this tall they were rubber
they were three inches tall for it they
were rubber and they were not
articulating they were all stuck in a
pose kind of like the California Raisins
oh I collected all those but Hardy's but
Smurfs had way more than the California
Raisins
do you collect all of them uh I don't
remember but again for me it wasn't
about collecting it wasn't like I've got
to get the Papa Smurf because I don't
have the full set it was about putting
them into a situation and again this is
usually on a rainy day getting it set up
and then just destroy all of it you know
I'm saying it was just like okay who's
the lion or lion that lion oh yeah liya
no liya north
lion-o's gonna come through and
thundercat on the Smurfs whatever that
involves yeah and thunder can take out
12 Smurfs at a time oh gosh yeah lion-o
has no problem with Smurfs right just
and he was just both good it was just a
hodgepodge it we didn't you didn't even
stick to like good versus evil
you were like good decimates good no
skill in my world Skeletor and he-man
could be buddies they could team up they
could both ride Cringer at the same time
that was fun Cringer didn't complain
battle cat I mean okay yeah get it
straight
so hey my room was way too messy to
create any sort of like lasting scene or
like set it up and and of course my kids
are exactly the same way like there's
not we'll get into what they have and
what they have had but it's not set up
in a way it's set up in a way to
interact with and violently
and then destroy at some point and it
had to be replaced yeah to me it was
just about the scene the perfect scene
that you wouldn't touch and if if people
came over like my my younger cousins
like Kurt one of his first memories is
coming over and getting very upset I
wouldn't let him touch anything yeah
it's it's not playing and like his mom
my aunt aunt TC was like she thought I
was strict I mean she knew I was strange
but at that point she was like that boy
is strange and hey I also think because
I'm an only child and I was like I was
in my room and you know it was my Haven
and I had to build these worlds that
like then I would just admire and like
perfect you know I think that's that's
the operative word right I've got to get
I've got to perfect the collection then
I could perfect the scene and don't
touch it and this is my this is this is
where I'm god I'm in control and it felt
really good to like have it all together
and also didn't have like you an older
brother that was like well I do this and
if you want to be cool and and aspire to
be older then you might want to do that
so at first maybe that
a little Thundercat action when he's not
looking you're gonna steal it and
decimate your Smurfs but then later it's
like hey man I'm I'm kind of done with
toys I'm I'm more of like a cool sports
dude so why don't you come outside or
we're gonna we're gonna play a game
where we hide in the woods in the dark
be like uh-uh
count me out ya think that coal would do
with you right we were definitely
outside if you could be outside we were
outside and I'd it wasn't that I didn't
go outside like but me going outside was
an extension of becoming GI Joe I don't
know if you remember this but I had this
I invented this elite group of kids in
Harnett County called the army
investigators and like I had a trapper
keeper that had like a dossier in it and
like missions and I drew maps of my
neighborhood and I would go out me and
well I was the only member but then you
would come over and I would take you on
these missions and I would have like
Jimmy my stepdad at the time his gift to
me would always be stuff from the army
surplus store which was really cool if
you think about it cuz he took my my my
love for GI Joe and he said let's bring
this into the real world not with guns
but was like um built-in binocular vests
like the binoculars vest like the
binoculars that I that are in the in our
book that I still have at home in my
bedroom now when I spy on my neighbors
he gave me those camouflage binoculars
and I would take him out and well and I
in I wasn't a part of that and then we
did the same thing so I think this is
just he shows you what the geography
does the fact that we live like two
miles apart was it might it's um before
we were riding bikes across town to each
other right so cuz Jeremy Fisher who
lived on my street and then my brother
Cole and I were the explorers and we
called ourselves the Explorers because
we had duck boots that were set
explorers on them okay and so that you
know how like behind my house there was
the Buies Creek went behind my house and
down into the woods and how all those
different parts of the creek were named
different
forts like fort you and fort dead man
and then fort Buies Creek no what are
you talking about did you two know about
this no fort Silverstone but you made up
these names
Jeremy was so my brother was like three
years older and Jeremy was like two
years older and then me and then like
Peter Dinklage next door we're kind of
all a part of it and and you name
different points in the creek for
different fort names yeah and then we
would go out there scene it wasn't
Jeremy Fisher the older guy who kind of
like well yeah cuz I mean you play well
you've played with all the kids in your
neighborhood so and then and then later
I would spend a bunch of time out there
by myself as I got to go check on Fort
Buies Creek today see the only guys in
my neighborhood were those those two
twins who lived on the other side of the
cat lady miss Bolden yeah and um the the
shoo-shoo twins or something I can't
remember their names sounds like it was
a good s ue the shoe twins
she lived in a shoe they were I they
were older they were scary and they rode
dirt bikes when the army went out
investigating and stay is steer clear
the dirt bikes what else did you play
with so Smurfs uh obviously transformers
I had transformers I have I had a lot of
transference to interact to me
transformers were state they're separate
from this first group which is like
poseable because there's a mission with
those like you change them they're
active you change them from one thing to
another and they weren't easy no and
there's like a puzzle so I had a bunch
of those I have optimized Optimus Prime
was my was my favorite thing I played
with him a lot
I had the like the third generation
maybe the second generation that do you
remember the Constructicons I think is
what it's called it was like
construction equipment like bulldozer
they were yellow and purple and they
were bad guys and they each transformed
were they in the transformers world oh
yeah they were they were
Decepticons and they would but they
would all transform
into one huge thing so it was like
Voltron that was awesome so you had to
collect each one and then when you got
all of them you could create a huge
robot did you do this successful oh yeah
I mean I would have never been capable I
posed the hell out of that guy before I
before I would set him up and let him
lay yeah I mean before I got to one of
them would have broken too significantly
before I was able to collect all of them
and put them together look at the
picture man okay I remember that guy
that I like I mean one two three four
five there's at least six guys in there
and I also had a cool man
gobots no you didn't yeah I did
you had you had the cheap stepchild of
transgender and they were they had a
cartoon too now the interesting thing is
so I was looking these up because I was
like what were those called that and I
just put in Transformers ripoffs and I
got a list of the 10 worst Transformers
ripoffs see if you remember any of these
because I only remember ago Buzz Gobots
is number 10 and they were and they were
all they just remember they made the
same thing we're looking at this picture
well a lot of cars made a man I just
remember that they did not I'm playing
the GoBot World very loyal like super
simple cars that became this other guy
now there was also a robo Force nope
never heard of it
converters never heard of it zài BOTS
zy BOTS yeah
starry oars like starry oars like
warriors but was a star it's a cool name
Road BOTS Road BOTS no Robotron nope
mysterion's nope rocks and bugs and
things are you reading an ad now no no
that's it transforming things oh and
then rock Lords that turn into rocks
yeah that's um that's sadly derivative
and just sad
they transforms into a rock give me a
break the Transformers were amazing but
the funny thing is I never watched the
television show or the movie and the
movie is like a cult classic the
original yeah and they talked about it
in the Netflix series
well I don't know if I want to of course
I can spoil it right spoiler alert if
you want to watch the amazing
Transformers movie which I personally
still have not seen then mute right now
cuz I'm about to say Optimus Prime dies
he dies he's doing the one made in the
80s yeah yeah yeah stop-motion yeah
oh yeah the animated movie enemies I'm
not talking about the Michael Bay yeah I
know that well I wanted to I wanted to
ask you because I have a theory so my
favorite toys were what I call the
subversive category of toys
what Garbage Pail Kids oh and then mad
balls I do not know what a mad ball is
oh you don't know what a mad ball mad
balls were probably my favorite toy that
I had and because Garbage Pail Kids were
like baseball cards but they were they
were demented children who all had like
something nasty about them
yeah don't remember these mad balls they
were oh you talk about like us it's like
us it's like a cush ball but it's it's
like a it's a monster's head and my
favorite one was the eyeball it's a
smoosh Apple ball that you can throw
this like made of like this that's mushy
material but not the stress material
that we had today it was perfect for me
because it was a ball so it was the same
gross it was gross and it was like a
character but it was also a ball that
could be thrown it could be thrown it
Smurfs
if they can kill a smurf you can tend to
get wipeouts you know a hoard of Smurfs
with one mad ball you're like a
homicidal maniac but the Smurfs no no
what do you got against Smurfs
I was just get they're easy targets man
they're just sitting there looking so
happy they need to have their world
ruined you were like from time to time
you are Gargamel you are I love Gargamel
yes you are him I always incarnate
connected but Gargamel the darker
characters Gargamel's a cat can't go
that way he's got his flaws he's not
perfect but did you have Matt you didn't
have Matt balls because you know about
but did you have Garbage Pail Kids
I had Garbage Pail Kids but I
feel good about right so that that my
theory was is that those things that
were a little bit that were darker yeah
you moved away from yeah I don't know
that's real trashy twisted man it made
me feel what were you afraid of what was
gonna happen and we didn't talk about
this the funny thing is is that we were
best friends I mean I've got a lot of
time together but it was worth it folks
if you don't talk about your feelings
about Garbage Pail Kids yeah let's get
into the finer points about what's your
hang-up with garbage pail I mean I'm
surprised that was your friend if I
never went to your house and saw you
decimate Smurfs cuz I would have been
the end I I did I didn't again it wasn't
that wasn't something was something I
did on my own I ret I was a sweet tender
child and again it you see me at the
Magic Castle I mean I'm just I'm pure
man but I still mess things up you know
it's like I mean you look it they're
they're back to by the way I'm sure
Garbage Pail Kids had a resurgence look
at Barbara Barbara she's literally
vomiting into the thing she's cooking on
the stove it's pretty awesome they are
they're they're so great you know and
you could have that and it was tell me
another one
tell me another one we got uh Shh joking
Cooper choking Cooper is being being
constricted by a large snake he's dying
yeah he's dying he's being killed by a
snake Vincent van gone oh this is a kid
who has cut his own ear off just like
Vincent van Gogh oh my gosh Shepherd
would love this sharp shawl a kid who's
ridiculously large teeth have punctured
his own face the people who come up with
this are the type of people well they're
like you big hearted Beverly is hugging
two boys so hard that they are
suffocating is so wrong man Oh smiling
Stan that's just Stanley Stanley was a
garbage but no that's a that is
that is a reissue I believe or that made
to be a Photoshop oh yeah
Paris embarrassed yeah we got into these
yeah you got into some got in since
modern modern takes some Mima fide
Garbage Pail Kids
but like drippy Debbie I did have them
because a lot of people had them at
school and I felt in order to be cool I
had to at least represent theirs for me
there was just something about things
that were you know we were in such a I
mean just we were in the world of kids
you know and there are those that you
want to subvert that a little bit just
to feel alive I see the thing that I I
think the last toys that I ever had were
my WWF now WWE yes action well they're
not action figures they were not
poseable they were like made of they
were thick and they were made of rubber
and they didn't move but you could buy
the rest of the ring you know I had a
lot of those yeah and those were very
cool they were very big and here's the
thing toys back then I remember I would
go to Sky City and I put my bridge layer
my GI Joe bridge layer on layaway and
I'd pay like four dollars at a time
until I could spend the $30.00 to bring
it home but I also go there and buy
whenever I went I would look to see what
wrestlers they had it was hard to get
toys like the whole collecting thing it
was very difficult cuz it was all about
local inventory and they may not have
the one you want
oh yeah so I never had any good
wrestlers I never had macho man I never
had Hulk Hogan I I mean I would just go
and be so desperate to get a wrestler I
like Bruno San Martino what like I'm not
saying he's a crappy wrestler but for a
guy I mean like he didn't Rhine ever saw
that guy wrestle he was like a like he's
an old-school wrestler that for some
reason for a nostalgia sake they made I
didn't who he was but I bought him
because I needed to buy a wrestler
there's always like Todd Johnson like a
guy who's just wearing like a singlet
well no they were they were all
legitimate wrestlers but yeah I never
owned Hulk Hogan or Andre the Giant
really well because they didn't exist
and there was no Amazon so nowadays I
mean there's a resurgence and all these
toys for adults because we want to
the experience I'm having right now is
the reason why you can go on eBay and
you can buy a Skeletor or a Hulk Hogan I
never got that Hulk Hogan imma get it
now but put it on my desk man that kind
of thing you know there's a booming
business of collectibles for that stuff
there's that place in Pasadena you know
where they have like the glass the glass
closets and they've got all the all the
other collectible stuff in it but it's
not like but our kids are ready to get
anything they wanted yet they don't want
any of it because it can't compete with
the endless supply of digital screen
Ajmer well okay so I wanted to talk a
little bit about the toys that weren't
screen-based that our kids had cuz I
think that there's a lot of crossover
here between our kids yeah and some of
these things are in common with what we
had nerf we had nerf so but for us nerf
was for me nerf was mostly just a nerf
football that was what I thought of his
nerve I didn't have that I recall any
nerf guns but I had Nana Papa's house we
had a bunch of blasters that Colin oh we
did had the ones that shot the little
suction cups mm-hmm and now the Nerf
blasters I mean there was a point at
which I asked Arsenal's I built an
arsenal I built this giant I got some of
that like stuff that you put in your
like shop so you can hang up tools with
the holes in iron with the hole holes in
it and I got and I built it and put it
on locks wall so that he could have all
his Nerf blasters like just ready for
the taking and he wanted he and Lincoln
wanted to start a channel where they
reviewed nerf guns because that was the
thing for a while yeah yeah so that was
something that they and it was super
active I mean you can yeah draw your own
conclusions or have your own opinions
about whether or not it's you know good
for kids to have fake guns but the next
thing with Legos but but they had a lot
of that it was super active they they
they all had Legos and we did two legos
were Legos is like that is amazing how
the staying power that they have
I mean I think it's through the
licensing of like all the other movies
and whatnot but well and it in my house
there still to this day as a just a
couple of giant bins yeah of Legos your
house there's a bunch of bins of Legos
but they're like meticulously organized
like actually not anymore really like
there's times where I would come over
the house and your kids would like have
like every color organizing a different
bin and yeah like building something I
pass it the disease along but now what
we do is like Lando's only one who still
plays with him and he'll lay out a
bedspread and we'll dump out the bin on
it and then you'll start playing but the
last time he did that it broke my heart
because when I dumped out the thing in
the bottom there were like 85% complete
sets that I remember putting together
with Lincoln I don't know six years ago
and then they were in the bottom of this
bin just like eroding and I just I
couldn't take it
but Lando didn't care and he was just
playing with all of them and we don't
really we don't buy anymore he's eight
he's getting out of it right well some
people don't some people stay on
beyblades so yeah they play with those I
like it was so cool like Locke was so
into beyblades explain what it is so
basically it's uh I don't
I believe that it may have been a TV
show first I don't think so yeah I ended
up becoming a TV show anyway it is the
spinning tops that you you ripped you
pull this ripcord to start spinning the
tops and the tube beyblades go into an
arena and battle each other and the
first one to stop spinning loses and
like you would get you get a collection
of beyblades he played it with his
cousin's played it with me you know that
was something that we Lincoln had that
he got into a lot I just remember him as
like a four year old Bay Bay Bay Bay Bay
Bay does what he wanted for so bad that
was a cool toy yeah because it was
competition that you had to pull a
ripcord at least you got a watch out
that's a very like 80s style toy yeah
that's completely you know the whole
deal is analog beyblade let it rip
and they were into that and then they
and I think Lincoln had the same thing
and a funny thing is is like Shepard
really didn't care about beyblades
because the difference between a 14 year
old and a 10 year old even the 13 in in
eight or nine is that our youngest two
kids kind of came up with screens were a
bigger part of their play time then for
our older kids who had more of those
tangible toys yeah because we never did
you know Shepherd has Legos but he did
he doesn't play with him as much as
locked it and he doesn't have any
beyblades he played with the Nerf
blasters but not as much as Locke did
they also had those spider-man wrist
things that could that could shoot shoot
stuff that was here's the thing like
yeah they had those gimmicky one-off
toys like the modern-day version of the
Hulk hands you put the big Hulk hand
over your hand he smash it together
smash but that's not a that's not a line
of action figures that's not a robust
world of toys that then you could watch
the cartoon or a movie about you know or
create your own I mean it wasn't it
wasn't an immersive type thing
I was trying to search for that I was
like what what action figures exist now
I think that's what I googled and then
Google told me what'd you learn
just Marvel movie stuff I mean just
movie action figures basically but it's
not a big deal like if you walk down
that aisle you'll see you'll you know
you'll see infinity war poseable
characters but it's not it's derivative
you know it's like it's not the main
thing of course the Star Wars toys are
still around so those are action figures
now but the magic is gone but the action
figures them if it's just an action
figure that doesn't do anything if it
doesn't shoot something if it doesn't
light up if it's not part of some AR
experience then it really beyond
collecting you you're basically just in
the world of
collecting things and there's only so
many care about that and I mean pristine
example of collecting things now are
these pop figures which all my kids I
think Lily and Lincoln are finally
getting out of a but still and this kind
of goes into adulthood like if you
really like a property you want to have
that thing sitting are out and if you're
my kids you don't want to take it out of
the box you know you have the hawkman
pop figure somebody sent that to you
I've actually I have a bunch of hot
bunch of figurines you know different
versions of him that people have sent me
but it's they want to have a physical
representation of their best screen
experience so toys just fills that slot
it's like what can I have in the real
world that represents my jam' little
screen world but they don't spend time
posing or those are doing your voices
foreign plane they don't as mother they
don't play with it they just some ladies
other they display them and that's it
well in one of the things that kind of
ties into this is it's not just about
screens because I want to talk I want to
talk about you know how we counteract
that a little bit mm-hmm with some of
the tangible toys but it definitely is
the death of retail is a big part of
this you know so obviously this is the
year that Toys R Us went under for good
mm-hmm and at least I did they stopped a
website or is it I don't know but the
retail all the stores closed and I would
thought I would have thought okay well
they closed because of Amazon right they
quote that they're being impacted in the
same way that lots of retail stores are
and that's true they're being impacted
by online shopping but it wasn't it
didn't it didn't follow suit that all
the purchases that we're taking place in
retail moved online because year over
year in September nerve was down 30%
mm-hmm and this is largely attributed to
the death of Toys R Us okay so they
still have a website a website but
because there is something about being
in the presence of toys going going -
you know we used to go to brindle's we
talked about that yeah brindle's was a
weird department store that had for some
reason my dad had decided that brindle's
is where we get toys for the boys and
lawn care equipment you get anything
there it was kind of like a Sears and
but there's something about under -
going and seeing it picking it up
picking it up in the package that is a
completely different experience than
just looking at something on the
Internet I mean we experienced the
beginning of this I remember going the
change I remember going to Toys R Us and
instead of walking down the toy aisle I
would go straight for the Nintendo and
Sega aisle and what they would have is
they'd hit they had retrofitted aisles
that used to have toys on them and it
would have it was flat and it was like
laminated cards you remember this that
if you'd flip up and you could look at
the what would be the front packaging of
the videogame and then if you flipped it
up you could read what would be the back
of the packaging of the videogame but it
wasn't it was a representation of it
where you could read about it in person
and then they had locked cabinets where
if you got some what you're like I want
Street Fighter - yes it cost $75 in 1990
whatever it was I'm in late eighties but
I'm gonna get that and then they pull it
out of a glass case and give it to you
it was just like it was it was it was
laminated flappers and they dedicated a
whole long row of Toys R Us for that and
that was that was the beginning of the
downfall so well I can I can read
flappers on the internet once the
internet happens yeah and what I think
the operable question is but what do we
do with our kids at this point you know
it's like I feel like Lily she's 15
she's basically not a child locks not a
not not that type of a child they're not
a toy shot they're gone
Lincoln's gone namely just Lando a
shepherd I mean so with Locke in fact
failed them we were I was talking with
locked of the day you know he sees he's
playing basketball he's he's taking you
these difficult courses or whatever he
got this am course and he was like we
were talking about Red Dead Redemption -
coming out and he was like I I mean
first of all he didn't play that he
didn't play the first one he he didn't
play games that much but he was like I'm
never gonna play that because I don't
play video games he's like I honestly
don't have any time he's like I do
homework I practice basketball and I do
some social stuff but it's just like
there's not a place for video games in
my life anymore like and I I've been
feeling that way right 20 years but and
he's probably a little exceptional
because he's they place so much
basketball right like lint yeah
Lincoln's big into the games that he
plays on xbox but it's like it's I feel
like with the older ones it's kind of
like okay they they've kind of got their
thing again once they play video games
are not they they're kind of on this
track they're gonna do once you're eight
or nine you really don't play with toys
iam I'm feeling this a lot with Shepherd
who's ten and right now as was evidenced
by the the call from my wife and the
middle of the podcast I'm she's out of
town I am taking care of the boys by
myself I don't even know where they're
at right now no someone was watching
them right now but he-man wouldn't know
I am you know I've got Shepherd and the
perfect specimen of muscularity and
masculinity he would know if he were
dead
lock is he sterile though he's taking
you know locks got all his stuff figured
out but Shepherd is like just wants to
be on screens man he just wants to play
video games yeah roblox is this thing on
the computer or be watching something
and I'm like and he has a limit on each
one of those and like Shepherd okay
times up you have to do something else
and I'm like go outside now first of all
it's not like it was when we grew up I
can't just say go outside and roam the
neighborhood you basically you're
confined to our yard but what if we said
yeah cuz land land Oh is a similar
situation the different the thing with
Lando that he's very craft oriented he's
very like inventive and artistic
and you know basically that boils down
to being obsessed with slime like he
loves slime because he makes it from
scratch and he like makes all different
types and he like looks at the videos on
how to make the different types and but
he also does other art projects as well
and he's so he's he's not as screen
oriented maybe as how you're describing
Shepard but still he's very much it's so
much easier just to turn to the screen
we have to get him on his projects and
like get him all his materials and but
I'm wondering what what if what if we
kill two birds with one stone go on ebay
start buying all these vintage toy toys
to like restart my collection I can't
believe I sold all my GI Joes in a big
cardboard box at a yard sale in my
nanny's front yard for like 20 bucks I
sold my entire I sold them all except
for medic and gung-ho my two favorites
but still and I still have medic I still
have both of them right man all the
other thing I read in the book so I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna collect all of
them and I'm gonna say that it's so that
Lando can experience toys but that's
really not the truth but that's a side
benefit we're gonna play together with
toys my toys I think that's a bad plan I
don't think it's gonna work well I was
getting kind of excited about it thanks
for crapping all over well I think that
you just I mean first of all if if Lando
is can I get he-man really into the the
crafty stuff you just keep giving him
more opportunities to do that if he can
occupy himself with that but you think I
think he could get in the amen
sheera Teela Cobra Kai like you will I
think you I think he might observe you
doing it that would be an interesting
study of his father
okay Lando get off the screen you're
gonna watch me play with he-man again
play with Hema I could bring some Smurfs
over right Reds coming over with his
Smurfs victims yeah I could teach your
kids how to kill Smurfs
that's kind of stood out the blowtorch
and burn some let's get to get let's
have playdates again you there no wid
the boys they're almost too old for this
ring lion-o let's have a play day who
was the blue Thundercat um I actually
liked him he was voiced by the by the
dad on Cosby Show remember when we found
that out a couple years ago oh yeah but
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bye cliff dad
no bye Claire's dead I think it was
Claire's dad was the voice of the the
bald he was more the tech guy he was
like what Donatello was to the Ninja
Turtles oh and I actually think after
wrestlers by the way I think Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles was the last toy it
ain't never got into him and those are
still around that that's an action
figure set in a world that still exists
for younger kids and I think that may be
what I'm looking for
well I I think what I'm looking for is I
was just I was looking at the he-man was
nuts them and just look if you don't
know about these characters they're all
so ridiculous because they were invented
from thin air by a toy company here's my
theory and I think you talking about the
crafty stuff is what okay he's giving me
this theory because there's like we've
done a couple of things like robot kits
and yeah the science C kit kind of thing
that's a big now when in Shepard gets
into those I is partly my fault and
partly my wife's fault we don't have
we're not patient and so if it's just
like can you help me with this can you
help me make this slime thing happen if
it requires me to step in I just don't
have a lot of patience yeah I'm just
like do what I did and just figure it
out man yeah man you don't you don't
really have tapes Smurfs and murder them
yeah but anybody you try you're
basically trying to be an 80s parent
Yeah Yeah right yeah my parents like pay
attention to me I don't want to pay
attention to my kids parents nowadays
ironically they are they are there is an
expectation that parents balls to play
with the kid guys you're too involved
that didn't happen in the eighth
the kids to be free so let's learn some
stuff on their own but I'm looking at
what is the hot in the toy inside our
hot list for 2018 why is it well there
first of all I'm gonna skip a lot of
these because they're just dumb now okay
Shepherd has a Nintendo switch and
they're in this lab Oh stuff you can
make all this crap but then you're still
do you're building a steering wheel and
a gas pedal out of cardboard but then
you're playing a video game don't let
don't fall for that
well you're still playing a screen but
the time that the crafty time that goes
into building that that's pretty
interesting well okay first of all
there's a freaking game you can play
with your Amazon Alexa called When in
Rome and Alexa keep score that's cool
I read about that because people from
various regions give quizzes from where
where they are in their own accents and
you play with your family
I think board games and like family
based or those are still happening and
that's that's um I think that's a very
important aspect of toys that still
exist and that I'm personally passionate
about but I'm getting to the things
along the way I want to point out a
couple things okay rise of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles epic sewer lair let
lairs playset that's bigger than my
mobile commands this is giant is taller
than this child that's very 80s child's
on his knees right yeah well I think you
kind of ruined it it's got a slide and
Michelangelo is coming down the slide on
a skateboard it's pretty awesome
that's pretty throwback but the thing
that I saw that I was interested in that
looked like a combination of a lot of
things okay was this last one when I get
to it this the thrill rides Bionic blast
roller coaster building set oh wow okay
well okay so this has a couple of things
right you it's like tinker toys it has
that you have the ability to build the
roller coaster and you know you put a
coaster on it a coaster no marbles
involvement because it for for many
years there was a marble
one thing that you could build like that
like but then it's included included is
a cardboard VR viewer which I guess you
hook up to your you put your phone in
there no no no listen because this gets
them in because it's still about screens
because now they can look it from the
perspective of the roller coaster and
then you see it and you ride the thing
that you just built I think that the
future is can you bring and that's why I
like roller coaster tycoon Sims that's
what I like the lab oh stuff because
it's based on the fact that they've got
this interest already in video games and
screens but it's bringing them out into
the real world into some sort of
tangible analog experience can I have
that whenever Sheppard's done with it
after two days well yeah we're gonna do
it and then I'm gonna put a bunch of
Smurfs on it and we're gonna run those
Smurfs over with the car so you're gonna
get my life lesson you're gonna eBay
Smurfs thinking about it you're joking
you're not gonna do this Merv part but
that's that's something that you know
sure once he builds it and plays with a
few times yeah bring it your house but
and then it won't have all the pieces
but at least next time I'm like Shepherd
can I use it first I guarantee you will
keep all the pieces then Shepherd can
have it he want it would be like mint
condition no no I mean you can buy and
give it to me if you want to do that I'm
not gonna buy it for so your family can
have it first that's ridiculous
yeah might get it for your kids as a
Christmas present since when have you
bought my kids at Christmas present
every year no you haven't
yes I have what did you buy last year
bunch of Smurfs yeah eat it no I get we
get your kids birthday presents and
that's the kind of thing we hold on do I
give you our wife's handle that man but
yes they have they they have things they
care about our kids futures yeah we're
kind of just along for the ride
not true we care about our kids futures
gosh what is so what all right let's go
into conclusion zone I'm you're gonna
buy Shepherd AVR based tinker toys well
I'm gonna call it a day I'm saying that
I'm gonna resurrect my he-man collection
I'm gonna buy more toys I'm gonna get
more toys for the kids because I
actually want to get them toys so
they'll get off of screens and if
there's a transitional moment where they
have to use toys that also use screens
then so be it
you're not just for Shepherd locks hate
what he's gone I whatever I screwed up
with Locke is done right you know and
I'm saying his personality and he said
the trauma is locked in you know he is
who he's gonna be right but those
younger Shepherd and Owen Sheppard
a couple more years liability some
muscular it's really it's ages 3 through
5 that you have to worry about and
that's over for us please loan it I wish
I had to read a book about parenting
gosh I miss toys man I just want I want
to be a child
it's not about my kids Who am I kidding
what happened to toys that was a
question that we're answering they're
done they are over they became digital
man they went on a sane are gone yeah
and yeah rare exception it's just for
weird people who go to coffee shops I
love all of Foley for games
I love tabletop games and I love party
games those are an exception not what
we've been talking about but the
quintessential action figure world is
it's gone and I'm mourn it will speak at
you again next week thanks for hanging
out with us and let us know hashtag ear
biscuits what toy you were obsessed with
and what toys kid your kids are playing
with right now
maybe maybe there's something that we
should be getting for our kids who's
still of the toy age and you can you can
tell us what we should get them yeah
let's do it
we'll talk at you next week because we
love you so much
[Music]